and this is so unfortunate it makes me
so sad is that
these kids are going to be changing
their minds in a few years i say five to
ten years
so where what is this this is going to
be august 2020 when this comes out
so give it five to ten years there are
so many kids who are saying
why did my parents let me do this why
did mental health why did medical
professionals let me do this
they are going to have issues from being
on hormonal treatments from surgery
i'm already seeing all of these young
people these detransitioners and it
really breaks my heart and no one is
listening to them and no one is taking
them seriously
and it's there are going to be tons of
class action lawsuits
the title the end of gender i thought
was kind of interesting because
it's like you're you're dealing with and
unpacking
all of these seriously complex issues
related to identity and gender
and everything else but you're calling
it the end of gender
do you think that what we're left with
at the end of this conversation if we
can truly have it honestly
is that gender won't matter won't exist
what do you mean by the end yeah let me
clarify because when i announced
this when i announced the book on social
media people got upset at me because
they thought i was saying that this
is like the very super woke far left
right end of gender and that gender
doesn't exist anymore or that
gender is completely what you want it to
be and it's based in self-identification
and there's no tethering to biology
or objectivity and that's not at all
what i'm saying and i really want to
emphasize
i'm asking you that's why opposite of
that
i'm saying gender is very much
biologically based
and it is the misinformation and denial
of science and denial of biology and
denial of evolutionary psychology
that is leading us to not have a proper
understanding of gender
and that's why i see its demise yeah
so so paint the picture that turns some
of this around
besides just some people getting braver
like
the political part of this even i mean
when you see at this point
all of these you know the lgbt
organizations
uh that at this point i think are just
basically using gay people to now push
the gender stuff i mean what what has to
happen to them are are there non-profits
that are fighting this
from a correct scientific perspective
like what has to happen now really
what i see happening and i actually have
a line in the book where i say i'm
appalled
and i love i love the gay community and
i have many gay men who've reached out
to me over the years complete strangers
who say to me thank you for saying what
you did
because i was one of these children i
actually had one individual reach out to
me tell me around this around the time
my first op-ed came out he said i was
thinking of transitioning
and i read your op-ed and i decided to
wait and i'm so glad i did
so there is a line in the book where i
say i'm appalled at the number of gay
men who are
in support of transitioning children
because this is leading to the
extermination of gay kids
and what i really think is going to
happen and this is so unfortunate it
makes me so sad is that
these kids are going to be changing
their minds in a few years i say five to
ten years
so where what is this this is going to
be august 2020 when this comes out
so give it five to ten years there are
gonna be so many kids who are saying
why did my parents let me do this why
did mental health why did medical
professionals let me do this
they are going to have issues from being
on hormonal treatments from surgery
i'm already seeing all of these young
people these d transitioners and it
really breaks my heart and no one is
listening to them and no one is taking
them seriously
and it's there are going to be tons of
class action lawsuits and
i already see good clinicians in the
field who are concerned
because they know it's coming and and
they feel at a loss
because we've been trying to raise
attention and get people to take us
seriously but they just call us
transphobic
right and by the way it's not just the
personal issues and the medical issues
and everything else there's going to be
an insane amount of legal issues that
pop
up there i think there's going to be
kids you know they'll be young adults at
the time that are going to start suing
their parents i think they're going to
start suing
the doctors and probably everybody else
involved i'm sure there are lawyers
looking at that right now there's got to
be right and i would say to your
audience
too because i'm sure they've been
following these issues as well
pay attention to the people who are most
loudly and proudly embracing this and
saying this is great for the kids
because when this time comes they're
going to turn around and say
we had no idea this was going to happen
and they're going to pretend that that
they had no idea when they are coming
after those of us who are speaking out
about it
i know it's a little weird to be ahead
of the curve isn't it because you kind
of feel like you're behind it sometimes
as as the things start to come true i
feel the odd thing and when i was
writing this book i felt the whole time
it was a very emotional process for me
because it felt very much like
those of us who see it it's like we're
able to see the future and we're just
trying to scream as loud as possible to
get people to pay attention
don't i know it i know it uh you just
mentioned the deep the detransitioning
part of this is there uh a lot of
literature is there or a lot of research
on that as far as how many people
have done it are they happier after are
they suicidal after i mean
what do the numbers look like on that
there was one study
in sweden that looked at people who had
transitioned and then trans so changed
the the
marker on their legal documentation and
then changed it back
and they found that about two percent of
people who had transitioned
changed back but the thing is not
everyone who detransitions does it
legally
and also the data collected for that
study uh it finished around
2011 i think it was so that was before
this huge
influx we see of young people especially
young women identifying
as male and i've written quite a bit and
in the book i talk about rapid onset
gender dysphoria which is this
phenomenon of young women who are
very quickly identifying as male wanting
to transition to male taking
testosterone again getting double
mastectomy
when they are very gender typical as
children it's usually very
out of the blue usually they have other
mental health issues like autism
for a lot of them they have sexual
trauma that's not being talked about
and so we don't yet have the data for
that we don't know what that's going to
look like although there is one
county in the uk where hundreds of
d transitioners are coming out and
saying i'm i have autism
i'm lesbian and why didn't people
why didn't why didn't professionals you
know do what
they should have done which is ask me
questions
yeah i can't imagine discussing anything
almost more controversial than that you
couple this sort of rapid transition
with
autism and then you get you know people
to try to talk about that it's like
no one's good you could see why the
average uh researcher just would just be
like
no way i'm not doing this no and it's
difficult enough to get a study
published you know to get funding for
your i mean the book i talk about a
number of situations where
researchers have gotten approval and
they've got money to do their study and
still
they have to deal with all these extra
roadblocks that pop up or people coming
after them and threatening them
so at the end of the day you know the
science is taking a very unfortunate
turn i think we're going to look back on
this period
with with a lot of horror and
disappointment
but i'm hoping that the
the outcome is not going to be that
terrible if we start speaking out about
it
yeah have they done real research on the
the social pressures
related to all of this so like when you
mention the rapid onset where suddenly a
whole bunch of girls
that otherwise like it sort of appears
out of nowhere in essence
um that could it be from a peer group
and then they're really doing these
things that are just
really just crazily extreme to fit in
in essence yeah so this the one study
that's been done on rapid onset gender
dysphoria to date uh was published in
2018 by lisa littman and she did
the research did suggest that there's a
pure contagion aspect to it
in that these girls so for forty percent
of the girls in the study who
had come out as trans very quickly they
had at least
half of their their friend group also
identify as transgender
which is 70 times the rate of what you
would see in the general population
in terms of people who identify as
transgender so that
in itself should raise a red flag in
most people's minds
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell